The third issue has to do with Extensions.
Components are often extended by adding new features.
Recall that we met features and
features diagrams when we looked at architectural views.
When the vendors add new features complicating situations may arise.
For example, the particular situation might require that there
be exactly one instance of that particular component.
This is sometimes called a singleton extension.
If there are multiple components involved, we might want to ensure that at
most one of the, one has this new feature added to it.
Related to that is what happens if there are parallel extensions of,
of multiple components in the same dimension.
If we do allow the same feature,
feature to be configured into multiple components, we may need to be aware of
the possibility of resource contention, if each version,
version of that component is trying to get access to the same resource.
Sometimes there are non-orthogonal extensions, and
we have to be careful of possible feature interactions,
if a customer configures in more than one new feature at the same time.
And then there are recursive extensions.
Some component models support adding components that can themselves be extended.
This may mean that the component vendor loses control of what
components are actually deployed.